à l'âge de 20 ans bouteflika voulait
être président donc toute sa vie a été
guidé par cette quête quête
obsessionnelle
[Musique]
farida il est journaliste à jeune
afrique
auteur du livre bouteflika l'histoire
secrète aux éditions eyrolles le livre
ça représente 20 enquêtes
c'est à dire que j'avais commencé à
travailler sur le personnage c'est le
côté flic a depuis 99
[Musique]
depuis je n'ai pas eu de cesse de
travailler celui j'ai interviewé quatre
de ces prix mobilise des ministres à lui
des généraux à la retraite des officiers
de l'armée des diplomates des gens
d'affaires des amis d'enfance alors
bouteflika est né au maroc il a vécu
toute sa jeunesse au maroc et on sait
qu'on 6-2 en appel à déclenchement de la
guerre d'algérie et l'appel du fln de 56
pour les étudiants et les lycéens de
rejoindre le maquis
peut-être qu'ils colisée d'oujda où il
était scolarisé il ne lui mois d'après
pour répondre à la tête et quand ils se
présentent en novembre ce compte six au
lieu de recrutement le large au
recruteur capitale eh oui lui demande le
fait sortir le monde dégagé parce que de
l'autorité publique
le le cadre de beauté fait carré le
passé de collaborateur d'indicateurs
l'informateur de l'administration
marocaine ou française ensuite il a
fallu l'intervention une autre personne
pour que enfin le recruteur accepte qui
rejoint la ln il fait un stage de deux
mois deux mois en tant que contrôleur
ensuite voilà il rejoint devient un
maquisard
ensuite il a il rejoint devient sa
secrétaire de lebron james qui deviendra
plus tard président la république
il travaille aux côtés de boumédiène
jusqu'à jusqu'à l'indépendance
boumédiène le disait que bouteflika
était un beau panel les c'est vrai c'est
un excellent tribun maîtrise l'arabe et
le français
c'est comme si qu'il a eu c'est comme si
il avait fait du théâtre toute sa vie
c'est quelqu'un qui sait charmer les
foules qui s'est parlé et qui sait il
aurait pu faire du syntec
je n'accepterai nous aujourd'hui ou
demain une ingérence étrangère
quelconque dans mon pays et quels que
soient les résultats des élections
cette facilité à s'exprimer ses talents
de tribun ont fait que ça a beaucoup
servi dans
dans sa conquête des gens ses conquêtes
même des responsables à 20 ans donc il
voulait être président avant même la fin
de la garde agen emporte ministre des
affaires étrangères dans les années 60
et 70 il et il avait une relation
presque exclusive comédien donc c'est
comme s'ils se préparaient pour être un
jour le successeur du bon maintien
il s'agit d'une mission très
confidentiel vous me permettrez
gentiment de ne pas vous en parler
en soixante dix huit à la mort de
boumediene il s'était presque presque
autoproclamé comme le successeur naturel
ou héritier désigné de bonnes notes il a
été écarté par les généraux par les
colonels par l'armée on profite de cette
difficile à regarder mais en revanche je
suis dans la cud qui a alimenté cette
quête
cette obsession en politique
je crois qu'il faut mettre ses
ressentiments originaire il a toujours
attendu son heure est enfin soit 7
heures arrive en 98 à la démission de
président liamine zeroual est là les
militaires après plusieurs semaines de
d'hésitation des négociations accepte de
le désigner comme le successeur de
bouteflika c'est un intérêt de du
pouvoir et perd présidentielle et bien
parce que beaucoup plus pour que ça il
est laissé modèles sont kadhafi benali
tunisien ben ali moubarak ou saddam
hussein on voit beaucoup plus ces
modèles de gouvernance ce sont les
modèles monarchique il faut pas oublier
qu'il a vécu au maroc pendant 20 ans
donc il est imprégné de cette culture
monarchique et pour lui le pouvoir
s'exerce d'une façon presque
autocratique autoritaire et donc dès
qu'il est arrivé au pouvoir il avait dit
je suis le président je suis le chef du
gouvernement je suis le rédacteur en
chef de l'agencé officielle le patron de
la télé où le peuple algérien cependant
avec clavier aujourd'hui pour les
équipes que j'ai développé massivement
et choisit l'animé diop qui est la
sienne il pouvait pas s'imaginer céder
une parcelle de ses pouvoirs et la
travailler pendant ces 20 dernières
années a consolidé son pouvoir à
accaparer tout le tous les leviers de
commande si bien qu'il est devenu le
seul pouvant
il y à 3 bouteflika eux
le premier mandat où il était en plein
possession en ce moment il ya un an
quand de santé il y à une deuxième phase
de sa présidence il sert de 2005 où
d'ailleurs il est lui-même avoue qui la
font front de la mort est là il est
affecté psychologiquement et aussi
physiquement il est de plus en plus on
rentrait de voyage - il est moins
présent et là il cède petit à petit ses
pouvoirs et ses prérogatives à son frère
saïd devient un espèce de deux régions
de président bis ensuite il ya la
troisième phase la plus dramatique et
peut-être même être la plus
catastrophique pour le pays c'est la vc2
2013 là il devient paralysé il est sur
un fauteuil et il parle très peu
ils voyagent plus il ne parle plus aux
algériens ils ne le soit parce que plus
ses collaborateurs
c'est devenu un président fantôme et là
c'est l'un ou son frère saïd a pris
véritablement parce que le pouvoir quoi
il aurait peut-être partie de sortir par
la grande porte en 2013 avant son avis
mais il a quand même
il a quand même tenu à faire un
quatrième mandat malgré son handicap
malgré sa son âge on allait on aurait
pensé on aurait attendu âgées lien
attendait que en 2019
il cède enfin la part qu'ils quittent
ils pleuraient plus quitté les affaires
du pays
peut-être pas avec les honneurs mais
avec moins de défiance catala a présenté
un rapport sur la situation sécuritaire
au niveau national ine mourir au pouvoir
et il a décidé de faire un 4 d'un
cinquième mandat en dépit du bon sens en
dépit de la
est ce cette candidature à ce qu'il
montre qu'il a fait table
[Musique]